monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le président de la
commission des finances monsieur le
rapporteur général mes chers collègues
après trois mois de travail en
commission et trois semaines d'un examen
intensif mais attentif en séance
publique avec pas moins de 3000
amendements en discussion nous voici
réunis pour nous prononcer sur le projet
de loi de finance pour 2023 adopter en
nouvelle lecture par l'Assemblée
nationale après engagement par le
gouvernement de sa responsabilité sur le
fondement de l'article 49 alinéa 3 de la
Constitution nous vous le disons
clairement monsieur le ministre nous
regrettons qu'un aussi grand nombre de
mesures adoptées par le Sénat n'est pas
été prise en compte par l'Assemblée
nationale et le gouvernement dans le
texte final
Bruno Le Maire nous avait indiqué en
ouverture des débats être à l'Europe
visiblement il n'est pas aux milliard
prêt plusieurs mesures volontaristes de
rationalisation des niches fiscales
autrement dit d'optimisation des
ressources publiques adoptées à
l'initiative du groupe Union centriste
ont ainsi été balayés d'un revers de
main par l'exécutif sans la moindre
explication ni même parfois le moindre
chiffrage de la part de Bercy
les crises sont devenus omniprésentes et
il nous faut composer avec elle la
multiplication de ces crises a pour
inéluctable conséquences de détériorer
la situation de long finance publique or
le resserrage du robinet budgétaire par
la Banque centrale européenne et la
remontée consécutive des taux d'intérêt
sur les marchés financiers nous invite
collectivement à la responsabilité c'est
dès l'année prochaine qu'il aurait fallu
engager les comptes de l'État sur la
voie du redressement plusieurs
amendements de notre groupe qui une fois
de plus aura eu le sens de ses
responsabilités y aurait contribué
nous l'avons dit à l'issue de la
première partie et nous vous le redisons
aujourd'hui nous regrettons de ne pas
être parvenu à élargir la contribution
exceptionnelle de solidarité à
l'ensemble des secteurs d'activités
économiques au-delà du seul secteur de
l'énergie s'il est parfaitement légitime
que la collectivité publique Vienne aux
chevets des entreprises lorsqu'elles
sont en difficulté il est non moins
légitime que ces mêmes entreprises
lorsqu'elles sont en meilleure santé
concourent à l'effort collectif
d'assainissement des comptes publics de
même la suppression de l'article 5
autrement dit le maintien de la CVAE
perçu par le bloc communal et des
départements auraient permis à la sphère
publique de sauvegarder immédiatement
près de 4 milliards d'euros de recettes
fiscales tout en préservant l'autonomie
financière des collectivités locales
malmenées depuis de trop nombreuses
années
parmi les mesures adoptées pour soutenir
nos collectivités territoriales
figuraient la réintégration dans le
fonds de compensation pour la TVA des
opérations d'aménagement et d'agencement
qui y étaient devenus inéligibles du
fait de la réforme de l'automatisation
nous avions volontairement laissé de
côté les opérations d'acquisition par
souci là encore dans limiter le coût
pour les finances publiques le
gouvernement nailace pas conserver la
disposition du Sénat pourtant légitime
est nécessaire au regard des
investissements élevés engagés par les
collectivités
par ailleurs nous avions
substantiellement simplifiée et
renforcer le filet de sécurité pour le
rendre accessible à un plus grand nombre
de collectivités touchées par la crise
énergétique et afin de leur permettre
d'aborder plus sereinement les échéances
à venir
le gouvernement lui-même semblait
admettre la trop grande complexité des
critères retenus dans le dispositif au
titre de l'année 2022 or que fait-il
pour l'année 2023 après recours aux 49,3
il réintroduit ces mêmes critères au
détriment de l'intelligibilité du
mécanisme et donc en fin de compte des
élus locaux malgré ses griefs nous
tenons monsieur le ministre à vous
remercier pour nos échanges toujours
positifs et constructifs tout au long
des débats ainsi que pour votre
disponibilité et vos positions
argumentées nous sommes en revanche
nombreux à déplorer l'absence répétée
réserve faite de l'ouverture de la
discussion générale initiale du ministre
de l'économie et des finances sur des
sujets aussi cruciaux pour l'avenir du
pays nous pensions que la configuration
politique actuelle pouvait contribuer à
ses yeux à la revalorisation du rôle du
Sénat
sans surprise la commission mixte
paritaire qui s'est réunie le 6 décembre
dernier n'a pu aboutir favorablement
comme la rappeler le rapporteur général
un trop grand nombre d'articles restés
en discussion
contenu non seulement de l'échec de la
CMP mais également d'aider les prévus
par la Constitution qui rendent
impossible l'examen complet du texte en
nouvelle lecture le groupe Union
centriste adoptera quasi unanimement la
motion tendant à opposer la question
préalable je vous remercie
merci chers collègues la discussion
générale